hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the history of the
infamous Wizarding Dynasty the gaunt
family this prominent pure blood magical
family is sometimes also referred to as
the house of gaunt you may remember
hearing the name here or there over the
course of the Harry Potter series but if
you're having trouble putting your
finger on why the name sounds so
familiar allow me to remind you this
once proud and Powerful Dynasty is the
ancestral family of the dark lord
himself Voldemort let's start from the
beginning the early history of the gaunt
family with a long and dark history
known details of the gaunt family can be
traced back as far as the 1600s the most
notable member of the family at this
time was a witch named Gormley gaunt
intend on preserving the family's pure
blooded lineage it is said that she
murdered multiple members of her family
in order to accomplish this from there
the gaunts fam family history doesn't
get much brighter throughout the
centuries the house of gaunt was largely
involved in keeping the Chamber of
Secrets protected from Discovery within
the walls of Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry you may have
found yourself wondering how such an
ancient chamber had been kept hidden for
so many centuries well the goat family
is the answer in fact one Corvin is
gaunt a student at Hogwarts during the
1700s was given credit for keeping the
chamber concealed during his time as a
pupil while a new plumbing system was
installed within the castle the next
couple of minutes of the video contain
loose spoilers pertaining to Hogwarts
Legacy specifically these spoilers
address characters noctua and ominous
gaunt notable gaunt family members in
the game nothing major but I thought I'd
give you guys a heads up I'll put a
timestamp in the pinned comment for if
you want to skip this section and move
on to the rest in the 1800s there were a
few members of the family who could have
offered the House of Gourmet a
Redemptive narrative alas it was not to
be so noctuar gaunt was one of the few
members of the family Dynasty to oppose
the God's excessive use of the dark arts
as it were she wanted to learn more
about Salazar slytherin's Legacy in
order to uncover his true views on The
Wizarding World in her search for
answers noctua discovered a secret
entrance within Hogwarts to Southern
scriptorium a small study containing
salazarin's personal property including
his own Spellbook and his diary it is
said that this diary contained an entry
that describes Southern's disagreement
with fellow founding member of Hogwarts
godric Gryffindor regarding the
acceptance of mugglebones to the school
the diary also apparently mentioned the
Chamber of Secrets The Serpent of
Slytherin and Salazar's pure blood
supremacist views all of this however
was hidden behind several layers of
complex puzzles which included a door
that required parcel tongue to open one
of the final doors is said to have only
opened if the witch or wizard who
desired access used the cruciatus curse
which would only work if they had
someone to perform the curse on being a
gaunt noctua was able to speak parcel
tongue to enter the scriptorium but as
she entered it alone and did not have
anyone to perform the cruciatus curse on
at the final door she was trapped inside
never to be seen alive or heard from
Again by the end of the 19th century the
gaunts were still obsessed with
maintaining a pureblood family lineage
believing that mud Bloods and Muggles
were beneath them in fact many if not
all members of the gaunt family would
routinely perform the cruciata's curse
on unsuspecting Muggles just for fun it
was around this time in the late 1880s
that an ominous gaunt attended Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry
ominous had a reputation within his
family for refusing to perform the
cruciata's curse for sport as so many of
his relatives did sadly his refusal to
join in on the fun resulted in ominous's
own torture which was performed by his
immediate family his mother and father
included the magical torture bestowed
upon ominous gaunt by his family is
rumored to have made him blind and as
you may have suspected resulted in him
breaking all ties with the house of
gaunt And yet when he attended Hogwarts
ominous alongside a few of his friends
followed in his aunt knocked to his
footsteps and entered Southern
scriptorium arguably to find answers
about his ancestors tragically all he
found here were noctua's remains It is
believed that he only narrowly escaped
himself due to his companions performing
the cruciatus curse on each other in
order to open the final door
notable members of the House of gaunt's
family tree the gaunts were known
descendants both salazarin and Cadmus
pantheral salazarin was of course one of
the four founding members of Hogwarts
Cadmus peverel on the other hand was one
of the Three fabled Brothers to have
received gifts from Death In The
Wizarding fairy tale The Tale of Three
Brothers found in the book of the tales
of beetle de Bard Cadmus was the brother
rumored to have been gifted the
resurrection Stone a stone that could
bring loved ones back from the dead and
was referred to as one of the three
Deathly Hallows
with famous ancestors like these the
gaunts were so intent on keeping their
bloodline pure that they often married
their own cousins this of course makes
the house of gaunt's family tree a
little complicated the following witches
and wizards however are some of the most
notable within the family
gormlagaund lived in the 1600s and is
said to be possibly the most evil witch
to have ever lived at one point in her
life she possessed Salazar Southern's
wand Riana gaunt was gomla's sister and
mother to assault Ser who co-founded the
American ilvermorny School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry
Governors gaunt lived in the 1700s and
as mentioned earlier helped conceal the
Chamber of Secrets while he was a
student at Hogwarts noctua and ominous
gaunt were alive in the 1800s both
rebuked the views of their family and
entered the secrets of their
inscriptorium while attending Hogwarts
marvala gaunt lived in the 1900s and was
the maternal grandfather of Tom Riddle
who of course later became Lord
Voldemort marvalo possessed a Signet
ring which unbeknownst to him had the
resurrection Stone set inside as it had
once belonged to Cadmus pavaral
evidently Tom Riddle was also unaware of
the Ring's true nature as he used it as
one of his many horcruxes marapi gaunt
the daughter of marvolo and mother of
Tom Riddle was an incredibly mistreated
witch who is said to have seduced an
unsuspecting muggle into a romantic
relationship the result being her
unwanted son Tom while pregnant with Tom
therapy stole the gaunt family heirloom
slytherins locket and sold it to support
herself years later Tom used the locket
as another one of his horcruxes morphine
gaunt was the son of marvolo and brother
of marapi he was also the last of the
House of gaunt lineage and when he died
so did their family's Dynasty House of
gaunt family traits being a member of
the House of gaunt pretty much
guaranteed that the witch or wizard
would possess certain traits or
qualities the most prominent of which
was the family's ability to speak parcel
tongue the rare Talent of communicating
with serpents and snakes it is said that
the preservation of this unique trait
was one of the reasons that the dynasty
encouraged inbreeding many of the family
members were also completely pure blood
until the 20th century attempts to keep
their lineage pure is another reason for
the many instances of inbreeding within
the house of gaunt sadly this practice
led to some substantial mental
instability in later generation of the
family the gaunt family Legacy as the
last known descendants of Salazar
Slytherin the gaunts were proud members
of the Sacred 28 the pureblood directory
of The Wizarding World supposed most
pure-blooded magical families it's
fairly safe to say that the Legacy that
the house of gaunt wished to preserve
themselves was a powerful pure blood
visiting Dynasty most members had
similar hateful views of those Wizarding
families with non-magical blood and they
were more than cruel in their treatment
of Muggles throughout the centuries the
family primarily resided in their
ancestral home in northern England just
outside of little hangleton at one point
in time the gaunt family is said to have
had much gold but as they enjoyed living
quite extravagantly they were eventually
left penniless in what became an
incredibly run down shank Morphin gaunt
the last of the gaunt lineage lived and
died in squalor and destitution this is
supported by passage describing morfin's
father Marvel agones in a Half Blood
Prince he as you saw was left in squalor
and poverty with a very nasty temper a
fantastic amount of arrogance and pride
and a couple of family heirlooms that he
treasured just as much as his son and
rather more than his daughter and with
that we've come to the end of another
video what did you think did I miss any
notable moments in the house of gaunt's
family history please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live